I would be we were talking about like if
a girl sleeps around she's right I I
felt like that's basic okay that's like
like I don't even think that's
controversial and like you know some
people will argue what the number is
right like some some guys will will say
over too
some guys will say okay you know the
most common number I get is ten a couple
of
which I found funny a girl doesn't sleep
with one man and become a [__] a girl
chooses to sleep with multiple men to
become a whole the common denominator is
the woman I'm so tired of us being uh
not owning bad decisions yes oh my gosh
because every oh my gosh every time on
my show it's gonna be riled up they
would say okay I would be we were
talking about like if a girl sleeps
around she's a [__] right I I felt like
that's basic okay that's like like I
don't even think that's controversial
and like you know some people will argue
what the number is right like some some
guys will will say over to [__] oh some
guys will say over ten you know the most
common number I get is ten okay that's
that just from doing it I don't really
care I'm not here to argue at what point
right but by and large the more women
are men a woman sleeps with the more of
a [__] she is okay and and then the
women will always say but what about the
men the men sleep around okay okay but
again again the common denominator is
you like it's one thing if you get
bamboozled by one guy okay we're not
gonna pretend that there's no men that
take advantage of women okay like we're
not gonna pretend there's no players but
how many players did you meet you can't
make the okay like now let's let's say
let's say five is the number of Horrors
so you met five players five not one not
you didn't learn your lesson the first
second third for fourth no no ma'am
that's you you can't you're just not a
victim do you think one excuse that
these girls could have and I'm certainly
not you know I don't don't know which
side of this I've fallen right now but
the date in game has changed because of
internet dating so dramatically in my
opinion that men have taken the control
of like they just expect sex from the
jump so now if you're a woman who's
holding out it's a lot harder to keep a
man interested when the the power is now
more with the men than it's ever been
and the expectation of sex is more
higher than it's ever been so for a
woman to keep a man interested long
enough to know if he's going to be a
serious Contender you kind of are not
force but more inclined to give them
that because you don't want him to go
along to the next girl because he's
going to get it there anyway and he
wants it I I think that's a fair
argument for the small percentage of men
that are getting screwed by multiple
girls but I think for most cases I think
in most cases The Leverage is actually
with the women because most men aren't
getting laid well I mean that was the
start that I sort of I can't remember
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
under 30. and then there's this like 80
20 thing that I keep hearing the number
one way that people like date now is
from online dating and women only swipe
right five percent of the time so if you
go on a date with someone online like
he's he's the one getting all the
matches because you matched with him so
he's probably in the top five percent of
men
so that means if I had like a lot of
swipes that means I'm pretty desirable
yeah yeah
that's great I mean um you
sure you're in the top up like what 10
of income how tall are you six full six
four so you're in the top um so only ten
percent of men are over six foot so I
don't I don't know what six four is but
that's so income you're probably top
five percent boom height you're probably
top five percent so yeah you could kill
it out here on these streets
so this is the problem for women though
right so competing for a guy like you
yeah they probably would
you know and I don't really fault people
for wanting what they want like if a
girl wants to be single and childless
okay go do it you go after your career I
don't care but it's like don't complain
later so if you want to compete for
those guys that's a choice right like a
girl competing for you that's a choice
so you you might have to but I also
think men are willing to wait if they
think it's genuine the issue the issue
with like guys nowadays is they just
don't think it's genuine because they're
like what you're a virgin at 28.
like why am I waiting like that that's I
think that's how guys have told me they
see it yeah but we had like a girl that
was a virgin on her show that I actually
genuinely believed and she has no
problem having high value guys
interested in her because it's genuine
yeah I did meet one girl who was uh an
older version like late 20s and I just
remember being like you are really
playing this odd the hard game you know
looking for the prince yeah I had um I
had a what do you call it a video called
your virginity doesn't count if
and and one of them was like if you're
over a certain age I think guys start to
think well why are you a virgin like
have none of the men met your standards
is something wrong with you a million
things yeah yeah I think there's a happy
medium and once you hit 25 Anova men are
like yeah surely yeah do you not like
how can you just like I immediately
would have thought you can't be that
into sex because at some point the urges
are going to take over no matter how
sensible you are or she was really
overweight when she was younger that's
the other thing it doesn't count if
you're fat like no one you want like
trying so for you then you know you're a
tall girl women tend to like men taller
women tend to like men who make more
money than them is that would you say
that's fair yeah that is fair you're
you're really [__] all right now I'm
sorry no my stats are so bad because
you're a guy owner and you're tall yeah
I know do you think you're gonna have to
compromise yeah no I definitely will
um I've gone for guys shorter than me
yeah so I mean otherwise what dialogue
men love taller girls as well guys don't
care yeah they don't give a [__] I mean
I can't do like I don't want to say cat
but it would be tough for me if it's
like crazy but I'm like six foot so
um I don't know like five nine it's okay
yeah we're letting them know yeah and in
terms of like income and stuff like that
that's another thing that women have
been big on on your podcast that they've
said like I want guys who are on six
figures and I feel like it's hard for me
to judge because it's like yeah I make
good income now but it's an internet who
knows how long this will last and it's
like what I talk into a microphone so
I'm better than a construction worker
yeah it's like because I talk all right
more tweets uh I some of these are just
so [__] funny strippers are horse oh
yeah yeah I did tweet that yeah I did a
show on that too I mean there was
another one where it was um the only
fans girls as well that you basically
called them out oh my gosh I was so
excited because um what's his face
tweeted at me
um Logan Paul's friend Mike say a lot
yeah I triggered him I was like I
triggered Mike I'm like it's not my
fault you dated Lana Rhodes seriously
like you did that anyways
um but yeah um I just thought it would
be fun money to just tweet basic things
and see if people argued and then
everyone was arguing with me they were
like oh well a stripper might have a
lower body count than your average girl
and I'm just like okay but she's still
selling her boobs for money and getting
naked like what else do you call that
you obviously come from I've seen some
of your family photographs like you come
from what looked like a very wholesome
family background so to you like I I
assume have you ever talked to people
like that like only fans girls strip us
that type of thing yeah and what is it
like for you when you are saying these
things and then then you're meeting
people and finding more about their real
lives and how because you said earlier
you had a an opinion of homeless people
that was then sort of explained did you
have any Epiphany when you meet these
girls or not I think some of them are in
bad situations and that's why they do it
but I still have
very little sympathy to be honest
because
um a lot of men are put in those same
situations and they're just homeless
like at least women we have an out I
personally don't mind like strippers and
horse that accept their outcomes my
issue is when they start whining that
men don't want to date them it's like
what did you expect you know pick your
pick your poison pick your battle the uh
I think obviously there are some men who
will date only fans girls but like like
I wouldn't even pay for one of the funds
yeah you know I I think men who do that
you know you need to go out loud why
would you your top five percent hey but
also like only fans tricks they are
picking a certain Road and and with Lana
she is a great example because she
picked the porn Road made millions and
then at the end of her porn career
denounced porn said it was horrible said
it was this said it was that said it was
the other and then I recently had a porn
star on my podcast a male porn star who
worked with her who said she wasn't like
that on set she was quite happy
fine she got Trek like royalty you know
so for her to go up and denounce it
because she's now being slut-shamed it's
because of the outcome she's blaming the
process because it's easier to be a
victim than it is to just hold your
hands up and go I've picked this road
and now at my bed ironically and after
lie in it and I think you've got a point
to be honest yes I respect the ones I
had one girl the one that Auntie you
know know the one that Auntie
interviewed she was so cool she was a
stripper and she came on Auntie's show
she like interviewed her one-on-one
and she's just like yeah I've made these
choices these are the outcomes
that's it she's not whining about what
the outcomes I just don't like whiners
look one of my generalizations and one
of my favorite tweets from you is I I
generalize and I will continue to
generalize but one of mine is like in
the with the women I've met and [__] me
I can't believe I'm saying this but here
we go
they don't like being wrong you know and
they don't take kindly to being told
they are wrong and whereas you're a
woman doing that to them you're
literally putting and [__] me I wonder
why um I wonder what would have happened
in your career if you'd have been a guy
and you'd have come up with all these
opinions you'd have been lynched
your head would be on a stick outside of
my Palace The Buckner Palace yeah I
certainly have an advantage because I'm
a woman I think a lot of people like to
see people like speak on things why do
you think accountability and being told
they're wrong is such a trigger for a
lot of women I think we don't really see
the world for what it is in a way
a certain age
we make there's a bailout so if you want
to sleep around in the old days you get
pregnant by the wrong guy now you got a
shotgun wedding you're stuck for life
nowadays birth control now if birth
control fails and you do get pregnant by
the wrong guy which some of you ladies I
just don't understand how you do that
like a million times but that's not my
battle now now then what what happens
next you can get an abortion for free
you don't you got to pay for it here so
now or you can give birth and give the
kid up for adoption or you can be single
live your best life and put them on
child support I also think that women
are like we're treated better in the
world and we're given more help by men
generally um just because we're young
women
um and that I think does go away a
little bit the older you get you know
the less like attractive you are there
is a correlation there and even like
let's say we're bad with money
um we can get free assistance from the
government benefits and if we get
homeless there's women's shelters and
then we can just claim abuse for a
boyfriend we don't have and get a free
apartment I just think a lot of times
whenever we have to take accountability
for a decision like how do you learn
accountability there's bad outcomes
there's consequences but for women like
we don't really have consequences for
much for bad with money we're bad
sexually like and you'll probably still
get married even if like even cornstars
get sorry if we say corn porn stars get
married from The Tick Tock thing yeah
because you you did Colin just to stop
you from getting blocked or whatever
yeah I don't I just heard it wasn't good
on YouTube yeah good idea I should have
thought of that before I interviewed the
porn star yeah but in terms of abortion
you've been quite uh vocal about that
that's quite an interesting one yeah I'm
very pro-life what is it about abortion
that you feel uncomfortable about I have
a personal anecdote to it where I've
been on both sides of adoption so my
six kids growing up I was the second out
of the six I was the oldest girl they
adopted three teenagers one teenager
they adopted when I was like a baby she
moved out so I didn't really grow up
with her two teenagers they adopted
after I left for college I didn't grow
up with them but they lived with us for
a couple years three teenagers that's
nine when I was 22 my parents sat us
down in a room
we were somewhere at a wedding I think
and they look at us and they say um you
have a brother and his name is Greg
and my mom actually got pregnant when
she was 17. and they gave that kid up
for adoption um same parents a lot of
people think different parents know same
dad but they were just young they just
started dating and they gave them up for
adoption
um and I actually met him when he was in
his 30s I was 22 or 23 when I first met
him and it was crazy how similar he was
to us like he walked like my brothers he
was had the same sense of humor he grew
up in a small town in the middle of like
rural Wisconsin and
um he owned like a sailboat company and
like sailed around the world and my
family is very adventurous and his
parents like had never left left their
Hometown and that's how crazy it was
like he was just like us even though we
had we didn't talk to him until he was
like 30.
and
um so that experience just kind of made
me pro-life because I feel like my mom
could have had an abortion and it would
have been a shame because now he just
became a dad he just got married and I
genuinely do believe it's a child I
think if people were pulling
um surgically
oh if they were opening up dogs and
surgically pulling off the limbs one by
one and then crushing the skull and
vacuuming it out I think people would be
outraged but some reason when we do that
with women
you know um nobody talks about it and it
a lot of people don't know
um that when there's a unique DNA
sequence that starts from conception and
that has um the baby's like eye color
hair color personality trait like that's
from conception I'm not going to pretend
like I'm a doctor like I know the ins
and outs of it but I just yeah I just
don't believe in abortion and I think
there's too many options and resources
for women to be getting abortions and I
think it's crazy because it's legal up
to six months and um yeah it's here you
can get it for free up to six months and
there's children that have survived
before that and like if you look up
videos I genuinely think everyone would
be pro-life if they saw a video of an
abortion because literally like imagine
up like a five month old child you're
which is mostly developed and they
literally pull the limb off pull the leg
off pull the arm off pull the middle out
and then they crush the skull and vacuum
it out and that's not good for women
either like I don't a lot they'll say
it's like a woman's right to choose
acting like this is something that's
going to help us when I know women that
are traumatized from having an abortion
we had a girl um that came on our show
and she even talked about how here she
didn't know that when she like she took
the pill which is like an earlier one
and she said she didn't realize how
developed the kid was she thought it was
a fetus and it came out and it was like
she's like it had a head it had fingers
and it was like traumatizing for her I
could see you're really passionate about
this and also I could see there where
you were talking about your brother like
how much that meant to you uh and it's
nice that it's not just like
I know you like to be controversial but
I can say that you're speaking from a
place of like real uh empathy there and
uh a lot of women speak about what
happens if they are attacked and
impregnated Etc
um what do you say to those people
because that would be something that
people are saying at the screen though
well um it's a really small percentage
of cases anyway I mean the data they
kind of hide the data on abortion it's
not very well collected but in the
states that they have collected in the
US it's less than one percent of cases
so um a lot of times like people kind of
use that as a cop-out in my opinion
anyway
um because it's like you're arguing for
one percent of cases what about the
other 99 but I I don't believe in
abortion ever I think it's really sad
when that happens I think I could even
go as far
I don't want to like die on this opinion
but the death penalty for rapists to be
honest um that are actually convicted
like the issue you would get into is
that false accusations all that stuff
you know but if there's a way to prove
he did it and it actually happened then
I could go as far to suggest the death
penalty for rapists but I just don't
think you can take that out on a child
like that the kid's innocent what did
the kid do and I think it goes back to
the the real opinion you have to have is
do you think it's a kid or do you not
think it's a kid
if you don't think it's a kid I
understand like the the people's opinion
on it because like why would there be
any problem if it's not a kid but if you
think it's a kid if it's not a kid what
is it is the question yeah I do
understand if someone is a victim of an
attack wanting to not go through with
giving birth with that child given you
know to raise the the the attacker's
child it's a hell of a an even just to
even give it up for adoption is a lot
but I overall I understand the other
side of that like if you know if this is
some people will just use it as a form
of contraception and which is insane
there's a girl that had seven abortions
Jesus I think 40 of women that get
abortions have had two or more
so it's just women getting them over and
over I mean what's the best predictor of
future Behavior past Behavior so a lot
of the women like half the women getting
abortions it's not their first have you
ever had an issue with saying this to
people like because I can imagine you
could trigger someone with this level of
oh yeah
um
absolutely I've had people stop ends
with me over
it's not hurtful yeah it was really
hurtful
because you come across bulletproof
right you're very calm I've seen people
challenge you but like you are you know
you're a woman you preach femininity you
know there must be moments where you're
not the the boss you know what I mean
that you come across like no um I would
say I actually so I'm pretty emotional
to be honest
um I don't
I mean I'm smart I don't put it on
camera you know um but no I had a friend
of 20 years stop being friends with me
um over this stuff and then she came out
and put like videos out about me I
didn't really want to give it too much
attention but
um yeah it's really sad to be honest
when you say I'm small I don't put it on
camera why what what do you mean smart
why you can't respond too much to like
trolls and like hater otherwise you're
giving them power you know because they
see that they can react to you and then
they make money and then they just keep
going so it's like if they see you get
emotional and they see you like that
they have an effect on you they're just
gonna keep going
um yeah and I just kind of look at it
like a job in a way or do you cry at
work it's probably not good to cry at
work yeah I I always think if someone
doesn't know you personally don't take
it personally yeah because they just
yeah like there was this chick who was
um you actually quoted the Tweet like
she there was a video that she made
about you where she was psychoanalyzing
you and then she was like playing with
she she wouldn't do this but I get men
to come and all this crazy and you just
literally caught it like she's crazy you
just laughed her yeah no she's nutty the
harder ones have been the people that I
know that have turned I would say
um that I didn't really expect when
crazy women offer their crazy opinions I
really don't care
like I just think they're stupid to be
honest
seriously of a woman who's like going
like this I'm okay like let me just get
take everyone's opinion though and uh I
mean like she was an only fans check I
think so she obviously had a vested
interested
she did say that but I I was just
laughing at you you're tweeting her but
one thing that you did say in regards to
birth control and and that sort of thing
on Twitter was I think this is a very
interesting question of can a man fully
consent to sex if the woman lies about
being on birth control yeah because the
women always say they can't like you
States um
I can say right
say that a guy raped you if you took off
the condom and you didn't notice
um so did you rape him if you say you're
on the pill and you're not that's my
question
um because when you think about it when
we have sex there's only one party I
mean minus the the exception they're
gonna be like what if you don't see the
condoms I'm like really you do okay fine
but but there's only one only the women
get all the information about the sex
because they we know if we're ovulating
or not or you should anyways
um you know if you're on birth control
or not and you assuming it's consensual
you pick who you sleep with where the
men it's like their their options are
condom or no condom vasectomy or no
vasectomy and the women also have plan B
abortion dot like all those other stuff
I was listing before so women have all
the information men don't that's why men
get like Bamboozled into children
they're like I thought she was on birth
control okay
careful top five percent
genuinely that's yeah that's a real
thing where like surprise you know it
the like there is no way that the data
like wouldn't back up like accidental
pregnancies being more common with rich
men than than poor guys well when you
think about it girls only ovulate like
what three days four days maybe five
total in a month but I think there's
only like two or three days you can it's
really likely you'll get pregnant so
when people say like oh it was an
accident I'm like
I I'm just a little skeptical tell that
to Drake yeah oh yeah like come on she
was probably like okay I'm ovulating
this yeah she texted me totally because
for those who don't know Drake oh you
know had a kid with a girl who was
basically on video done so naked and
whatever else well and a lot of these
women are predatory um I just did an
interview with the guy and he talked
about how
like women will book our towels by and
like NBA players right and these women
go to these games with the express
purpose of trying to get these men to
cheat on their wives like he talked
about one girl that he like dated later
and that she was so proud he's she's
like it took me two years but I finally
slept with that it was like a
professional hockey player she's like he
said he would never cheat on his wife
and I got him too like they like take
pride in that
there's like women that like they
they're Predators they they know
everything about these men so you think
you're running into a you're 21 years
old guy you just got in the league you
think oh this that girl at the bar is so
nice she knows exactly what you want to
hear she knows all your interests she
knows everything about you
and you just think oh she's a nice girl
you know and these women know how to
present themselves in a way that like
makes them seem like the girl next door
oh they make me feel like a king yeah
yeah that's the problem is men we're the
Chaser no you know what I mean so it's a
very strange thing then men just think
the best of the situation because they
aren't women have been told from day one
like say you know the boys and all of
that you know that was never yeah well I
mean we're all women I just think are
viewed as innocent and I think men just
have that they haven't you guys have an
innate protect like we want to trust you
yeah we want to and and I think you guys
have an innate like you like you want to
protect us too naturally and I think
women know that and there's certain
women that take advantage of it and like
how how common we'd always talk about
the player man we never talk about the
Predator women I mean in my space we do
but not overall on the media yeah yeah I
think one of the things that surprised
me about women the older I got was how
women could
reframe things and and and so like
you'll find yourself arguing with a
woman and
you realize it's a competition of who
can claim victim
you know like oh but you did that no but
you did that first but then you did that
and what led to this do you know what I
mean and like it's like [__] hell I
can't just be the I can't get a sorry if
I live my life depended on it yeah there
ain't no sorry it's coming to me like
have you ever seen those videos of like
girls trying to justify their cheating
like they got caught cheating and then
they start crying I'm like [__]
why are you crying like I saw this video
this guy and it could be fake you know
that but but things go viral because
people relate to it right otherwise
people wouldn't believe it and she
screwed like three guys while they were
dating she's like well you probably
cheated on me too and it's just like
okay can we talk about what you did
first that
my thing is I I I've gotten sorries from
a woman in a heated argument and then
I've been like and then immediately
afterwards comes all of the
justifications and I'm like you're sorry
doesn't mean anything anymore because
you've said sorry and then now you're
telling me why it was really my fault
the whole time I'm sorry but yeah yeah
if I hear but after sorry I'm like that
what the [__] are we doing there you
know this ain't over we're just still
going you know what I didn't understand
something I learned about man is man
really don't like when you say why like
when when you when they tell you
something and you're like but why why
like I didn't realize how annoying that
is to guys because we're just like nosy
or you know we just want to know we want
to be in the know and I didn't realize
how exhausting that is to guys to just
have to explain every little thing well
yeah because
luckily I think in this red pill space
that they are realizing like they're
coming out with a lot of things like men
are looking for respect in peace yeah
and if we don't get that
we will never be happy
it's women think it's about love and
that's part of it but it ain't all of it
you know what I mean and if we're
constantly being challenged questioned
and and not feeling like our opinion is
valid or matters then we will be in a
relationship thinking I want out and I
want someone who does do those things
for me yeah and that was actually one of
like the turning points I had with my
brother that like I was talking about
earlier was he I didn't realize that he
felt like
um you know that was disrespectful to
him and always asking and asking and
asking instead of just listening
old-fashioned men it correct me if I'm
wrong because obviously you know these
kind of guys it's like generally we let
women have their opinion on almost
everything but when our foot's down then
it needs to ma because if that if that
doesn't matter then then where is our
power what do we what do we we're giving
you you want the walls pink I'll paint
the walls pink you want the [__]
corporate screen you know what I mean
but like if if I put my foot down it
needs to matter but like it feels like
modern women really haven't grasped that
out tell you something I think that the
laws have changed how we interact in
relationships we always hear the phrase
happy wife happy life she wears the
pants right that those are common right
very common and would you you could
would you agree or disagree that more
women lead than men lead nowadays in
relationships one million percent yes
okay and I think about why that is
coming yeah go ahead men take in women's
last names or babies taking women and
women and men double barrel the names
like the all the old ways of like a man
being the head of the family even a name
is not the same anymore
and and I question why and this actually
came from one of the fathers for justice
guys that I interviewed and he was
saying it changes the way we interact in
relationships because think about it
okay if me and you are married right and
if I leave I get everything and you
leave and you lose everything you're
always going to be trying to make it
work oh yeah and I'm always going to
have one foot out the door and even if
we're not married we just have a kid
it's the same thing the men have more
incentive to make it work where the
women have more incentive to leave which
is why by and large and you know there's
exceptions there's guys that get good
prenups or figure out you know ways
around it whatever but by and large in a
society like the men are always going to
be trying to please the women because
even if they don't know all the stuff
about the laws I think men still
innately know they lose more than she
does
and women innately know that we get more
because we've seen someone get screwed
over in divorce like you don't know
anyone you're a shitty wife if you don't
honor your husband and respect his
leadership and then you said you're a
shitty wife if you don't sleep with your
husband yes and this is like basic you
know because
what city that do dishonoring are you a
good wife if you
'd sleep with him for five years like
that's what men want well that's the one
thing well one of your next tweets was
kind of piggybacking off of that which
is is it more common for women to get
fat after marriage or for men to stop
working after marriage
what are you getting out there just just
to understand that because the women
right
kids and I don't and I've said this I I
don't think men expect our bodies to be
exactly the same as when we're 25. okay
like that guys are reasonable however
they didn't expect you to gain 100
pounds Diane like like they didn't
expect he didn't expect that and so it's
like and then the girls will be like oh
he's out of shape too but I'm like he's
still probably providing more than you
are and so it's like we're in this
Society where men make more than women
but women are fatter than men and I know
they'll use the stat and they'll be like
when some women under 30 in cities make
more okay fair but over a lifetime men
tend to make more and I think it's true
because men over
you know I think men like want to work
longer like in their 40s 50s women are
like if someone is knocking and moaning
at home it'll do wonders for your work I
think
but also like yeah I hear you like men
are driven by by sex a lot more than
women are therefore women's looks are
more important than a man's looks men we
kind of rely on women loving us to still
want to [__] us rather than our physical
attraction you know we think bringing
home the bacon is actually what should
make a woman want to you know give us
what we want and have you ever had a
moment in a relationship where someone's
hit you with some home truths and you
found that hard to listen to yeah really
can you remember what it was oh actually
oh my gosh one time I tried to make my
ex-boyfriend his favorite meal and he
thought it was so bad oh my gosh it hurt
my feelings so much I worked all day to
make that I'm worked oh I worked the
entire day to make his favorite meal and
I was so proud of it and he said
terrible this is I used to be a pretty
bad cook I'm a lot better now but I used
to be pretty bad and that really wounded
you yeah I was really mad in my
experience I commit to London I started
dating obviously like women aren't like
they're not in a hurry to cook for you
like it's it's a rarity really yeah wow
yeah women in my experience like they
they weren't like any good at cooking
because they've grown up with this like
they all went to University they all
been living yeah yeah noodles they're
not like they live like teenage boys
these girls they're more messy than me
do you know what I'm saying relax I
agree with you you know what I mean I'm
[__] in London essentially because I I
came from old-fashioned mother who
literally like the house was so spotless
you know you've now been in with modern
women it's such a clash for me
um and I guess it must be for you
hanging out with modern women as well
I'm kind of messy to be honest
yeah no I'm trying to work I'm I'm
working on it but I definitely a messy
um I used to be a pretty bad cook too
but you can attest my cooking's gotten
better right
I cooked for the staff actually all the
time you got some controversial tweets
together should we believe women who say
that they were sexually assaulted but
didn't file a police report oh yeah um
I'm gonna say no no I'll tell you why so
I
that was my deep
ER girl says
oh I was assaulted oh I would like this
you know my your first instinct she's
crying she's sad she's emotional
whatever your first instinct is to
believe her and I used to on my show
until I started asking questions like
just as follow-up so she would say this
happened and I would say well did you
file a police report no
um but it to me it doesn't make sense
why are you coming on my podcast if
you're afraid to talk to the police but
you're afraid to talk into a microphone
to milli at 1.4 million subscribers or
three something like that it just didn't
equate so I just think we're a little
bit too quick to believe women without
any evidence a lot of these girls would
say my ex-boyfriend that I dated for
this long anyone watching the show is
gonna know who that guy is
and should we just believe her even
though there's no evidence we've no
one's even investigated it just based
off her word and in a way they're kind
of defaming his character and ruining
his reputation and in their because
people will see it right one girl came
on and said that her ex abused her and I
said well did you ever hit him
[Music]
she did and so it's like now you're
labeling him as an abuser when you hit
first
so how are you a victim how were you
abused and I just think we don't ask
women questions when they tell these
stories obviously there's some truth in
what you're saying in terms of some
examples you've given there I can't
argue with the toll and then
there's some victims who for them to
come forward and talk to the police
takes a lot of strength in a lot of
years before they can feel like they can
do that do you agree no really if
someone raped me I'm going to the police
someone punches me in the face I want
them to why would I not want to tell the
police I think for you I believe you
because you're very like confident
speaker I had a moment when I was a
young kid where a babysitter touched me
and I didn't say anything for years and
years not because you know it didn't
happen but obviously because
it just never felt um
right you know I don't know why I didn't
feel like anything like I mean that was
a different you're a kid weren't you
yeah I was a kid so that was a different
example but but I guess the point I'm
making is I've heard some victims talk
about things in a way that I'm like I
get why that would be very traumatic and
talking like you're scared that people
aren't going to believe you it might be
a often is a family member so when you
go to the police you're gonna [__] your
whole family up I mean yeah I could see
your point
um I think there are some cases where
um you know true yes but I I think by
and large should we just believe people
based on their word my answer is no I I
think you need some evidence one of the
trickiest bits is the evidence so if a
rape up in three months ago getting
evidence is very difficult well that's
why I think we should encourage victims
to go to the police that's my opinion I
think we should because you don't want
him to do that to someone else or her
right yeah I hear what your where you're
coming from I do think that does take a
lot of strength and not like you are a
very strong person that's clear and and
often people right after that happens
they're they're probably their worst so
I would suggest that I'm not saying
people don't lie I mean I've just
covered a story recently where this girl
smashed her own face in with a hammer
did you see that I didn't actually watch
I like saw the Articles
smashed their own face in with the
hammer and I was in prison after wrongly
accusing people so that does happen but
equally I do see the other side of it
um yeah I mean my whole point is I just
think we shouldn't have recorded public
opinion A lot of girls will go around
saying that a man abused them or a man
graped them or whatever with no evidence
and now we're in a point where his
entire character is destroyed in that
community and he didn't even get his day
in court if she doesn't like I I hear
you I think for me if if a woman comes
out and goes to social media before she
goes to the police that for me feels I'm
not comfortable with that because
if that happened why are you why are you
going to people before you go into the
police or even just like going around
telling the whole town about it so
you're going to tell everyone in town
and you're not afraid to do that but
you're afraid to go to the police it
just doesn't add up yeah yeah I I I
agree with you on that sense I think
there's some people who probably have
bottled things up for years and wouldn't
tell people like me and you in a public
forum but if you're on a public forum
and yet you haven't gone to the police
that doesn't add up yeah especially with
this girl she dated the guy for like six
years so everyone watching knows who it
is wow and you know at first like the
story is oh he abused me and then we ask
more and more questions like one thing
that girls always say is there's bruises
on my arm or something like that and
then you've come to find out well she
there's bruises on your arms because you
were trying to hit him oh and so that's
so then so she's like oh he held me down
so it's I don't know what's your take on
women hitting sorry on men hitting women
back after they've been hit I think from
a moral perspective I feel like if you
hit someone you should expect to get hit
back I could understand why men avoid it
because
what's that gonna like the police are
gonna take her side so what kind of
relationship do you see yourself having
do you think you will because this whole
production company has really taken off
and I don't see it slowing down and
it'll be very hard for a man to come
into your life and be like yo you're
getting in the kitchen now love like how
do you imagine that's going to work out
I really hope to be in a relationship
where I can trust uh my husband's
leadership
um and I want to cook I want to cook for
my family to be honest that's important
to me do you think you'd ever walk away
from all of that that you've created now
just to be a mother and give it up or do
you think you'll balance it if push came
to shove I would give it up what does
push come to serve me if I felt like I
could not raise a family and do this I
would give it up right okay I've got one
last question that I like to ask people
how would you like to be remembered
um
at the end of my life I'd like to be
remembered as a good friend and a good
mother and a good daughter
that's a great answer yeah thank you
very much that was Pearl on the true
Geordie podcast do check her Channel out
if you want to watch people having great
debates I really enjoy it and uh yeah
I've thoroughly enjoyed having you on
thanks thank you for having me this was
a lot of fun yeah I'd love to do it
again sometime yeah for sure um we
should you should come out on a show hey
I'd love to yeah that'd be great yeah no
doubt come on
come as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible